[Musique]
evènement c'est d'abord une rencontre
une rencontre entre les élus et
l'établissement public et les
professionnels de l'immobilier pour
permettre de valoriser tout le potentiel
qui existe sur notre territoire le
théâtre de paris saclay qui aujourd'hui
travaillent collectivement tous ensemble
on est tous autour de la table
et puis mon envie de profiter des 15% de
recherche publique des 15% de recherches
privées qui sont concentrés sur notre
plateau et faire en sorte que cette
recherche donne des fruits donnent des
fruits économiques qu'il y ait là avec
des entreprises en croissance qui se
développe sur notre territoire d'être en
quelque sorte une silicon valley à la
française
donc on a beaucoup d'opportunités que
qui vont de saint quentin en passant par
versailles vélizy courtaboeuf massy orly
le plateau de saclay bien autour du cas
le thouet ce qu'est le coeur du
dispositif
on a une opération internationale on a
besoin de partenaires privés et on fait
en sorte que l'on travaille tous
ensemble les élus les partenaires pour
faire une réussite de ce territoire
ces professionnels de l'immobilier qui
sont présents aujourd'hui des promoteurs
des investisseurs des personnes qui
s'intéressent au développement du
logement du logement on
générale du logement étudiant de
l'immobilier d'entreprise
on a beaucoup de d'excellents
professionnels qui sont présents c'est
une grande réussite murray
[Musique]